hey everybody its Jessie welcome to live
coding with Jessie if you're watching
this recording later because you were
expecting the stream to be later on at
my normal time 2:00 p.m. Eastern I'm
very sorry I I intended to stream at
2:00 p.m. and I tweeted that I would be
streaming at 2:00 p.m. and then about 5
minutes ago I realized that I had set
the stream to go live at 11 a.m. Eastern
time so I'm not even sure how many
people are gonna be watching this live
because it's it's so much earlier than
normal and I told everybody the wrong
time so apologies again but I thought I
could have either canceled that stream
or made it postponed it or I could have
just put out on Twitter that hey I'm in
a stream right now so I chose the latter
because they're already about 4 or 5
people waiting for the stream when I
found out so I didn't want to leave them
hanging
so I mean everybody I guess would have
initially got the notification from
YouTube for the right time so maybe
that'll help it looks like I do have
some people in here so awesome hey it's
actually not bad when I do it at a
different time sometimes there are
people who just can't watch the stream
at my normal time so now maybe we'll
have some new faces who watch the
recordings but don't get to participate
live okay so I'm I wasn't planning on
working on this yet I was gonna work on
some other stuff but we're gonna work
more on this as you can see I've done
pretty much nothing this still looks
kind of broken like we left it on Friday
so didn't work on pretty much anything
yesterday
I wasn't feeling well just stayed home
well I should say that I worked on my
Udacity project so I finally got that to
the point where I was confident to turn
it in so I don't have it ready to show
you today so sometime this week maybe oh
I'll show you all I don't have it up and
running anywhere
but I can just have it running locally
and just show it to everybody let's see
what else did I want to say oh okay so I
don't know I'm sure you all saw that I'm
sure a lot of you saw that we got so we
as in free code camps YouTube channel
got a silver play button from YouTube
which is really cool so Quincy made a
video and posted it last night and so
check that out if you don't know what
that is when a YouTube channel gets to a
hundred thousand subscribers they get
this silver play button
you know framed and it's really cool so
we're actually over two hundred thousand
subscribers now but it's still really
cool that we got that so I'm excited and
also quits
Quincy thanked all the YouTube people
and so my name was in there too and I
was just that was really cool I was I'm
still like I'm still very appreciative
that for this opportunity to to
contribute to free code camp so anyway
and I'm glad that I could help in some
way and you know reaching the subscriber
count that we have now okay let me let
me get started yes so we got we got a
decent amount of viewers right now so
let's go ahead and
get started so I said hello what's up
take my so so I think somebody wants me
to say their name on youtube so Abdul
Wahab I think that's it Abdul Wahab
sorry you all know I try really hard to
pronounce names correctly so if I don't
pronounce your name correctly let me
know all right so have a lot of people
saying congratulations in the live chat
thank you so much
I mean really it's you all that that did
that right I mean you you're the ones
that subscribe so yeah it's it's amazing
I don't know what to think that anyway
I'm gonna get to coding but I'm just
really it's just really cool let's see
all right so let me at least tell you
what I've done I've done a lot of prep
work to get ready to do this so I was
just really having trouble with this
design in terms of just not there's a
lot of content on the page so it's it's
really difficult because my design style
is usually like very minimal so I was
having a lot of trouble figuring out
like where where everything was going to
go how I could keep a lot of the content
and not have it be cluttered so usually
when I'm at the beginning stages of
design and I get stuck I just look for
inspiration so I looked at a lot of
material design sites a lot of you know
the Google Sites and I got some really
good ideas to incorporate at least I
think they look they're pretty good at
least the way they were executed on the
sites that I saw so I think it's gonna
work out I have a much more clear plan
now so let's get let's get to it
okay
let's build out this this the frame for
all the sections first right so I know
about how many sections are gonna be so
I think it would be better visually to
just have all those sections with some
headers in there and then we can start
putting things in and that'll maybe help
a little bit to get what's in my head
conveyed to you all as quickly as
possible that's always tough I usually
have but you know a vision in my head of
what it's going to look like but trying
to convey that to other people is not
always easy my my drawing skills are not
great so I try to sketch it out but it
never looks the same okay so let's see
we just need some we need some sections
and actually we're gonna we're gonna
take out a lot of this right so I I'm
done with the with the Carousel idea or
even the accordion so I have a different
idea for this section and then for our
news and events section so at first for
this section we're just gonna have a few
cards across and if we need to if we
really want to have more than a few
cards we could potentially just have a
large scroller all right so that it'll
it'll just shift across so we'll
probably build that I don't know I'm
thinking that we'll just build that from
scratch maybe we use what's with
materialise we'll see I'm undecided
still it'll be the faster way to do it
let me start my timer before I forget so
if you are new you haven't seen this
before I do 25 minute sessions of code
and then in between I do five-minute
sessions of question and answer and then
at the end I finish out and I'll answer
any of the questions that are in the
live chat so I always do at least two
Pomodoro sessions of 25 minutes I'm
definitely going to do two today and
then we'll see how things go all right
so let's just get some basics let's see
what name I gave this class so okay so
this is all in a container right now I
don't want to make everything in a
container I think what we'll end up
doing is having sections in those
sections that we want to be contained so
have this space on the sides here
we'll then put the container inside the
section but I would like to have you
know as we're doing here full width
sections so so like this so right now I
guess it's okay if I do these in rows
and one way I do do them in sections so
section there we go
oops can I do that no all right so if
you confuse this to what I was just
going right there Visual Studio code
comes with Emmet Emmet is a shorthand
oops a way to kind of do shorthand and
then have it automatically turn it into
HTML so I'm I'm learning how to do it so
far it's a really cool feature you can
see how easy that was
and so right now I'm just gonna put in
I'm just gonna put in the text it just
says column just so that there's
something we can see with this structure
not every section is going to have the
same structure but it's going to be you
know this will be kind of a nice base
structure that we can work off of is a
section with two columns we're gonna
have yeah so some of the sections we
will want that container in as well but
I'm not gonna put that in there right
now
we'll also want see let's put a header
in here as well h2 section there we go
alright so this will give us an idea
right now I'm thinking we'll probably
have another
I'm gonna start with with section but
maybe like five more sections and then
see how that looks okay great here's the
section for now I think I'm gonna take
out this banner or at least comment out
the banner let's just comment it out for
now okay and let's take out I didn't
want to put a different image in here I
just keep forgetting let's take out
these for a least change it up I'm gonna
go back to what we had originally which
was just a card like this just three of
them I I wonder I think I'm gonna try to
put in the actual texts that are in some
of these now on the main site that the
live version of this site and see how it
looks if we can get away with making the
cards a little bit smaller we might be
able to go with four across on a large
screen so I think I think that would
work out so this is what we want
and
all right so let's go inside this row
put two more of these in oh man what was
the there was a hot key there was a hot
key for formatting things automatically
what was it I don't remember what it was
um I'll have to look back at the last
video whenever I I learned what the hot
key was and then fixed that formatting
because right now that's terrible
all right this is make sure you did that
right okay great
let's grab grab some of the actual text
man are these is this a text it's just I
think that's part of the image is it
let's see
I'm gonna inspect that to see if that's
all just an image enough how do we have
five okay
okay so that's actual sex oh wow
all right okay so each each line is
actually in its own in its own div
interesting okay so I guess I'll just
type this out it seems like that'll be
the easiest thing to do so I'm gonna
move this over to my other screen so
that I can type it easily all right I
guess some answers to the Auto
formatting but I have have different
answers control Kennedy all right let's
try this
whoa okay the control k/d did not work
that did not work let's try this over
wish okay so for not working thanks for
the advice though I let's see oh I'll
figure it out I can always go back and
check the last stream okay I don't know
if you all noticed in the last stream
but several of my co-workers were
peeking in the door and doing silly
things so I didn't realize how many of
them were doing it and so they told me
after the stream and then I went through
and and saw it so I guess that'll be
some nice Easter eggs to look for now
okay so I'm not sure if we even want to
have the card title
there's not really anything now on the
card that that I think would be good for
the title
I mean unless let's try this let's try
to put the students name where the title
is and then include their quote and then
just have a read more link we'll see how
that looks
all right so Shannon and I want to put
this in quotation marks so it's clear
that it's a quote this automatically
type server and this instead of serve
okay that was good and then let's
see how it looks okay yeah that's that's
a really small amount of text let's try
to get away with doing four cards then
and so I could definitely I could see a
few benefits to doing four cards I think
five would be pushing it but four cards
would allow us to use much smaller
images as long as we keep it consistent
and you know potentially even on a small
screen we could drop down to two columns
so that we would never have anything
like as big as that right and then we'd
be able to display more you know right
away without having to click in one way
or another
and I'm open I mean I'm I think I'm
gonna suggest that we just we don't have
five stories like we have now I think we
should just have three or four stories
and then if we want to change them out
more frequently that's totally fine but
I don't know when it comes to like
carousels like this the statistics at
least that I've read show that you know
barely anybody ever gets to the fifth
one the percentage drops significantly
after the first and you know after the
second one so most users don't even get
to this point so I think it would be
better to just have a few visible
immediately and what the user is much
more likely to actually look at that and
read that I definitely want to set it up
so that these are always the same same
height so probably won't work on that
today I know we've done things like that
in previous projects so I may not do it
on the stream we'll just mostly we're
where we get with it
okay so let's let me add one more card
she's gonna add one more card here and
then let me change these so what we want
is this to be 3 and then medium can be
dropped to 4 that's gonna look weird I
think we don't want that let's go with
medium 3 small 6 ok so on small screens
each card each column is going to take
up 6 of their 12 columns so 6 of those
are going to be taken up by the first
column second column left 6 and then
over here each one's gonna take up 3 so
we'll show you what that looks like
ok so you see as we get smaller at some
point it goes to two okay and that's not
bad I mean I don't like how long these
cards are but I'm I'm okay with this
this isn't really you know this isn't
too bad and for right now I'm sticking
with the column classes that are built
in to materialise but if we really want
to have more control over things we
could always you know set our own
breakpoints do some different things
with that occasionally you know I've had
to do that okay so I'm gonna leave this
like this for now it gives a general
idea of what this could look like and
it's something that I could show my boss
to show other people to just get get
them thinking so normally the process
goes I consult with my boss or whoever
is has the information for the project
just kind of talk about some things
sometimes I'll scan
things out get some immediate feedback
then I go to work and actually build
something out just usually with a lot of
you know content like this right you
know obviously this is not ready to go
get alive but it gives you know a better
visual you know something you can
actually interact with then I go back to
my boss or whoever and get some more
feedback and it will change so what
we're doing now is probably not going to
be the final version of this but we just
want to kind of get our ideas out you
know actually kind of build out not
completely but just kind of roughly all
right so for the news section which will
be our next section I think I may have
some sections that are banners in
between just to break up all the white
but I'm not going to do that right now
we'll get everything on here see how it
looks and then see if we need that I
also have another I have another idea
that I might put into place I've noticed
on some of Google's sites that they they
don't have the cards automatically
visible they're only visible when you
hover over them let me show you an
example and I want to see what you all
think about that it's a little bit
different for me I'm not I'm not really
used to it
but I'm not I'm not opposed to it it's
interesting so here we go fine let me
bring this over okay so check this out
so this first this is the design Google
and so you hover over this and now it
becomes a card and the entire thing is
clickable down here it's that it's the
same is it
anything I thought it was for this I
guess not here it is okay so for these
ones it's the same thing it's clickable
now here's the the advantage of this I
think this is really cool so notice that
these are not the same heights but it's
not obvious that they're not the same
height right away but if you hover over
them you could definitely tell but since
they're never both visible at the same
time you don't immediately get that idea
that like wow these are really off right
so I love that because one of the one of
the big issues always when I'm doing
things with cards is you know getting
them all to be the same the same height
and sometimes I don't have control over
the content I advised that we you know
try to have uniform content and try to
have as little text content as possible
and but I don't always have control over
that so for instance here if one of
these were large this card I could get
the card to be the same height but
there'd still be lots of white space
inside it doesn't seem like it's not
obviously you know so different when the
white space is inside but it's still a
little bit weird sometimes so I'm
thinking about going with something like
this I don't think this is built into
materializes something we'd have to do
on our own don't think it would be that
difficult though so anyway let me know
what you think so I'm not gonna look at
the live chat right now but when the
timer goes off when we do our our first
five minutes the first part of that
first thing I'm going to look at is that
and see what you all think so for now
I'm just gonna do the cards like normal
but we may be switching to that that's
that's definitely going to be a
different it's going to be different
than anything else we've done so
so I'm okay with doing it because I I
think there are there are a lot of
benefits I think it gives us a lot more
freedom doing it like this so we'll see
but for the newsfeed I liked how it was
done here so not every piece of news has
to have an image right you we have here
and we may not do it exactly like this
we have one main piece of news that does
have an image and then the rest of them
we just have the the titles and you know
just a little snippet so I like that you
know we have the more news up here so I
think we're going to go with something
like this the news right now on the site
we have so we do have images but we
don't these images aren't always I think
the best right so certainly some stories
will have images that could be used but
I don't think every story necessarily
needs an image with it right I mean this
if we're going to use an image it should
add to the understanding of what's
happening all right it should draw you
know draw your eye like recive right now
I can't even read this stuff down here
it's hard to read this and I'm pretty
close to my screen right now so now
right if we add you know maybe a really
well-known person like like father
Scanlon really well-known at this
university so a picture of father
Scanlon would definitely be appropriate
to have for a news story but logos I
don't know
so I like the idea that in this setup we
could have something with an image and
things without an image and it looks
fine earlier the way I was going to do
it I don't know that it would look it
would look good we would be forced to
always have an image and a certain and
image with certain dimensions for every
story so let me check my time before I
try to implement this okay we got about
three and a half minutes so let's try to
do as much as we can here it looks like
basically we'll have mm I mean we're
definitely gonna have two columns see
we're gonna want these columns to be
inside a container
okay so we're already set up for two
calls we just need to add the container
first and then let's make I keep
thinking in terms of react component I
almost said we're gonna make a component
for this but we we can't we're not not
using react so which we're just gonna
write the mark-up for this for you know
for something like this I'm not gonna
try to match this exactly I actually
really don't like doing that I feel
weird copying someone's design exactly I
don't mind taking some inspiration from
it you know the general concept of
having stories with and without images
but you know I don't want to try to copy
fonts spacing everything so we're gonna
try to adapt it and kind of make it our
own
let's see so we have section right all
right so this is this I think it's the
section that we want you start getting
names on these sections it'll be a lot
easier and we can potentially break
these out into components if we need to
I think I mentioned that before if this
component starts getting huge then
probably be better for organization to
break it out all right so you say news
and we got to put this in a container
right so what we can do then is probably
the easiest way to do this I think is to
make the container just add the class
container on this section in previous
projects I've added a container inside
the section but I think maybe I had a
good reason for that and I forget but I
think it's unnecessary to have an extra
div just to add this extra class so
we're gonna try it like this I think it
should be fine
just to test it let's make sure this
should there we go so now this does have
margins on the side and let's
thank God I want to quit having to load
that image every single time so I'm
gonna comment it out for now the big
hero image I just I feel bad like
continuously hitting the unsplash was
unsplash thought I T sermons so my timer
is up now anyway let me find that CSS
file
let's take that
okay all right so let me go to the live
chat now and then we'll we'll fill this
in my my timer it's hidden there we go
all right okay
okay so so so Tony says I upload the
Google design cards okay cool so we got
one vote for the um I'm assuming you
mean like this this how we how they do
it here John says same hiding cards is
easy with Flex CSS attribute stretch or
in grid it's even easier now I know
great I will yeah I know there are some
ways that I have used that make the
cards getting the same height in the
card it's a lot easier let's see alright
so that seems like it was
it looks like that's that's all for the
opinions about the card design so I'm
going to scroll up and try to see if
there are any questions
Harshit says congratulations your silver
play button and may free code can't
progress it so it reaches more than a
million subs that would be cool
did they give you a gold button at a
million subs I'm not sure I would have
this I would imagine the next step would
be gold button right that would be
really cool to get a million
okay Brando asked about the IDE it's
it's Visual Studio code so I don't know
if I would call that an IDE but that's
the code editor that I'm using today
okay cool no D says it's been a while
because the streams are always late but
glad to see it today so that's awesome
I'm I'm really glad that you get to see
the stream now so I like I said I know
there are people that watch the the
videos that don't get to stream because
of the time so cool I'm glad you can
gladly ask it says am i late
yeah I'm I'm actually early so you are
you're a little bit late maybe about a
half hour I started that about a half
hour ago so but it's it's my fault I
started way earlier than normal without
very much notice to everyone
okay so nobody asks if I write unit
tests when coding unfortunately I don't
write tests when coding so I did have on
the last project Kevin who's frequently
in the in the live chat and contributes
on github set up some some testing stuff
and I did end up going through and
editing a lot of the the tests that he
set up and was learning how to do that
that was what do you say it was end end
testing so I would like to be able to do
tests I just am not really I don't know
enough about it right now I'd like to
find some good training materials on
testing right now I have no time to do
anything else until my nano degree is
finished so it'll probably happen is
I'll finish my nano degree by the end of
October then I'll probably have to work
on my talk for November then after that
I'll probably have time to learn
something new
in that case I think testing should be
the next thing I learned
we'll see unless something else comes up
anyway so I really do want to do testing
it's just not something that I've that
I've learned all right we got one
question at the end that I just have to
read so says which would you rather
fight this is Ruben says which would you
rather fight one hundred duck-sized
horses or one horse-sized duck is that
and this is so weird cuz I just I just
saw somebody else just ask this question
my cousin's husband asked this question
and she posted it on Facebook so where
is this question from I feel like I'm
missing some reference but anyway that's
a good question so I'm not gonna give my
answer yet if you'd like to answer in
the live chat let me know and then on
the next 5-minute break
I'll read out the answers and I'll give
my answer I would hate to influence you
all on such an important matter so what
would you rather fight a hundred
duck-sized horses or one horse-sized
duck that sounds like a good question
for my kids I gotta remember to ask him
later on they'll probably my oldest son
Rafael will probably just like try to
think it out for you know four hours and
he'll be trying to come up well maybe if
you did this all right
so okay cool let's build this now
where to go
there we go I'm like I'm gonna separate
these sections out with some spaces just
I can keep it straight I normally would
not put this many spaces between things
but I don't want to have to keep
searching for it okay
alright so in this section we'll have
and we want to give this hh4 maybe so
let's give it give it a div forgot
forgot to do that I'm gonna force myself
to do this I remember
so it'll actually let me let me put in
some of the actual news that we have
and
let's put this paragraph in here and
then I also want to put in let's put in
an image
when you grab this source over here wow
that's really cool that it automatically
puts the source and the all
text
and
okay actually the title is the link
so I'm not worried about that right now
but this will end up being a link let's
see what that looks like
and then I'm just gonna copy this now
and paste it here and then let's remove
this whoops I'm sorry I meant to remove
the image
and then we'll copy it a few times
I see that gives us
okay not not too bad at first so what we
want to do I actually really like the
idea of putting the date right because
right now our stories don't have the
date I mean that gives us the advantage
of let's say we don't update our stories
very often it's not obvious that they're
not updated but I don't know I think I
think I'd like to have the date in there
I guess the problem is right now if
we're not pulling the date in I'm not
sure how we would pull the date in
because I have no idea how to so like
this would be the equip setting this up
in Ektron which is the content
management system that this site uses
would be I don't know what it's called
an extra on but like in WordPress terms
it would be a custom post type so I
don't know how to make a custom post
type in Extron or to get data from a
post siphon Ektron so I'll have to learn
a lot more before that can happen so for
now I'm gonna leave off the dates
because I know for sure we can grab
these pieces of data because I can just
look and see how we're doing it now if I
do figure out how to grab the date great
I'll grab the date otherwise I'm just
I'm not gonna worry about it I'm
definitely not gonna worry about it now
we're just trying it you know show
something on the page all right so I'm
just I want to clean this up a little
bit I don't want to spend you know a ton
of time on it but I think there's a few
things that we could do so for now I
think these these titles are way too big
so we need to drop those down we
definitely need to get rid of that
character up I'm not worried about it
right now but at some point we need to
and then the image
I'm not sure what we can do about so I
mean ideally we would have an image that
took up you know the full full space
here but without editing this image I
don't see how that's gonna happen so
we'll just leave it all right so let's
drop these down what are the age for is
now let's try to drop them down this we
can see what age oops
what age five looks like
okay
I think that's all
multiple cursors is so useful okay all
right that's much better that's the size
that I was initially thinking of okay
great
so that's good I would probably I mean
this is pretty obvious that the title
goes with this text but you know maybe
we could do something add a little bit
more space here and tighten this up here
but for now that gives the general idea
the only other thing we want to have
here is you know like a read more
I guess we could put it over here the
only other place that would make sense
is to have something down here that said
read more
I'm actually not sure that we even have
that right now okay so we do have a more
link right now and it is at the bottom
I don't know why I'm thinking so much
about whether to put it at the top of
the bottom I think I'm gonna put it at
the bottom honestly and the only reason
why I'm gonna put at the bottom is as I
said I don't like to copy people's
designs exactly and so we are leaving
out some things but you know putting
putting this at the top I'm if there's
something that I can try to not copy
that's kind of not really important I
can put that down here so I know it's a
small thing but I'm just gonna put it
down here for now we'll see how how it
looks all right so let's get section
yeah you know the bottom of this section
let's put in
and for now I don't want it to go
anywhere
okay
so we're gonna have to style this a bit
right so I wanted over on this side some
suspect that and this might actually be
pretty simple well somewhat right so I I
do want it on this side on a large
screen but on a small screen you
probably won't look right on that side
so for now I'm not gonna worry about
that but I would probably want it
aligned this way on a small screen below
below these so maybe we can just
see I don't want to do it everywhere
there we go okay so if you can see what
I did there
so initially this was all the way over
here because when you use
position:absolute on an element it is
absolute in relation to the parent
element that has a position of relative
so if it's immediate parent element
which in this case was this section then
if the media parent element is not
position relative it goes up to the next
one so it went up to a probably this div
may be further up I mean obviously like
the entire window could be potentially
you know it could go up to there if
nothing has positioned relative so for
right now it shouldn't affect anything
on the page that I've made this position
relative but you notice as soon as I
made this parent div have a position of
relative this went right back into place
and now it is aligned zero pixels from
the right side of that div so for now
this is okay probably would not have it
be zero pixels I it might look better if
it was shifted in a little bit but I'm
okay with it for now but that's kind of
a really tricky thing with CSS
positioning so if you're having trouble
with absolute positioning remember
relative it probably took me years
before I finally remembered that without
having to look it up okay so
let me put
I don't know if I want to make every
section position:relative so I'm just
gonna put it in line for this one react
is ruined me in terms of inline Styles I
never did it before
wait what why is he giving me a green
underline don't use empty one style
that it these wispy styles was wrong
with me why don't I remember that
yet
okay for this one we actually have a
unique class so we can put that in the
CSS
I don't know what I called it now more
link okay
what can we do position:absolute and
right zero okay let's try that out
see I knew it was what did I do wrong
yeah
CEOs position
I just can't spell it's my problem there
we go okay a little longer than it
should have taken but now it not works
alright so cool so that's my my idea for
the new section for the events section
I'm not gonna put them in right now
because I want to check there's there's
been like some discussion of doing
events differently so there may be an
API that I can tap into to pull an
events so I'd like to get a little bit
more information before I put any effort
into how I'm going to display events
because I don't know that I think that
whatever I do is likely to change based
on what's decided about how we're
handling events alright so next section
well let me check my time all right
seven minutes cool for the next section
let me show you some of what my
inspiration is for these sections where
do I put my
okay so the Google developers sites at
developers.google.com also as you know
material design in use here but they
have so obviously you know these are
normal cards you know we're going to be
using those but they have these sections
here where it's some some visual things
so probably be an image in our case and
then they just have some information and
a button now acts I have done this
before on several different sites so
it's not something completely new to me
but I like how so when I've done it
before this has been very large so like
a big image complete sections lots of
padding but what's unique in terms of at
least what I've seen is how tight this
is right so this seems as if it's one
section and these are just a part of
that one section I really like that and
I've never done that before I think this
will be good for what we need to do
because you know if you remember on that
main site we just have so much
information in each section so we kind
of need a way to break that up since
we're not going to use these columns you
know for instance a section like this I
mean academics could be the main title
here but it's like what do we do with
all this information so I think we could
incorporate some of this and split it up
so that it looks something more like
this you know a lot of space but still
has information still has the name links
I'm just gonna pick some of this out of
here to put here just as an example
just to show my show my boss what could
happen and then he can start thinking
about okay what information is the most
important in this section what
information can we cut out what do we
have to keep and then now that he knows
the framework of how it would fit in
there it'll be much easier for him to
say all right this is this is what we're
gonna put in here right so that's not
really it's not really up to me it's not
really what I like to do so I'm not I'm
not gonna try to do it I'm just gonna
worry about design honestly it doesn't
even matter what I put in here you know
anything as long any placeholder will
work so I'm gonna use kind of this idea
for some of the sections and it will be
interspersed I think with sections
that'll be you know more like just cards
with information so you know for
instance something like this could end
up being more like you know a section
with with columns so we could include if
we want some more some more videos to be
honest with you I don't even I'm not
sure about it keeping these I really
need to do some some click tracking and
see how many people you know watch these
because that's the section that could
take up a lot of space so if it's not
useful to the people visiting the site
then we may as well you know just take
it out of there yeah so I think each of
these sections would work like that my
other thought I think I'll just put it
in this first design is that we don't
need to have so many sections so
academics and admissions I think
I think we could place them together so
basically our tagline is academically
excellent passionately Catholic I think
those should be the sections that we
have because those are the things we
want to emphasize to our potential
students so the draw of Franciscan
University it's in a niche market and
the niche market is people who are who
are Catholics who really want so the you
know teenagers who really want to you
know deepen their knowledge of
Catholicism alright because this school
is known for being really good at
teaching that it graduates the most
theology majors out of any school in the
country so that's where you know we want
to have such a passionate Catholic but
what we want to also do is is emphasize
academically excellent because our
reputation in terms of being good at
teaching Catholicism is established
right it's established and generally
it's not it's it's it's not usually
questioned among our target audience but
what we need to establish is our
academic excellence so I think we should
we're gonna do academically excellent
first which makes sense it comes first
in the tag line so that'll be what
people see and that should hopefully
give them some new information that
maybe they didn't know alright because
we want students to be able to feel like
I can get a really good education here
so that you know I can go out and get a
job we never want the dilemma of
somebody saying you know what I really
do want to come here because of the
faith part of it but I I don't know that
I'll learn a lot there or maybe they
aren't sure if they have you know their
major or they're not sure if they'll be
able to get a job when they graduate so
we want to reassure people about that so
I'm gonna try to split up the site into
two main sections the About section at
the bottom or I'm sorry it's at the top
now I think we should move the About
section to the bottom
so right right now I don't know I don't
see to be honest with you there's so
much texting it's so small I'm not sure
how much of it actually gets read right
now so and it's not the focus here it
seems like it's in between these two
things that draw your eye this because
it's just you know it's big the colors
are there I don't I think it looks kind
of odd
so that draws your attention and then
this is a picture all right with a
call-to-action button here so I don't
know that this is having any impact
right now I don't think it'll be a
problem and move this to the bottom all
right so that's that's the idea so for
now I'm gonna fill in the section names
and then I'm gonna do my timer just went
up but before I forget any of this to
keep it all straight I'm just gonna fill
in three section names right now and
then I'm gonna check the time kind of
see how we're doing and decide whether
or not we're gonna do the third comodoro
session okay here's our news section and
I'm sorry I I know that the formatting
right now has got to be just killing
some of you every time I see that
formatting like my heart hurts it's like
it's terrible so I'm I'm definitely
gonna fix that formatting and I'm gonna
look up the whatever the shortcut is to
format the before the next stream okay
so let's go
technically excellence
excellent and this will be
all right just make sure that look sorry
that's right stuff okay that's what you
want so we're gonna we're gonna cut this
down so we're not one two basically for
really four main sections this is going
to be a somewhat narrow section but so
not counting the hero section in this
before main sections so I'm hoping to
reduce the amount of scroll that needs
to happen in this site because right now
there's a lot of scrolling going on and
I've gotten you know negative feedback
for that I don't think anybody likes how
much scrolling has to happen so I'm
gonna try to cut that as much as
possible but there's still there's still
a lot of content so you know we can't
completely cut you'll cut everything out
all right let me I'm gonna set the five
minute timer but this may end up being
the last session so I want to just kind
of see how many questions there are and
and see what time it is
I'm actually getting pretty hungry so
right now I'm leaning towards not doing
another session and instead eating
all right so the question that I asked
you Oh in the last five minute break was
was from Reuben about whether you'd
rather fight one hundred duck-sized
horses or one horse esta so you all gave
your answers let me read out some of
these answers a huff hopefully we have
some code related questions as well but
James says a hundred duck-sized horses q
master says one horse-sized duck sounds
like less work if I have a spear or
something
one good head and done it's a good point
black bat says my 50 Cal sidearm prefers
one horse-sized duck that takes care of
Thanksgiving supper - I didn't even
think about that but that would be quite
a bit of duck meat if you had a horse
sized duck heights John Hansen says a
lot of smaller struggles are always much
easier to handle than one big one so 100
duck sized horses okay
James since a hundred duck-sized horses
build up my confidence as I defeat them
and give me better ideas to approach and
strategize my fight I might come across
an idea that will kill all hundred and a
blow ok all right so that's it for me I
think I'd rather go with the giant duck
sized horse or I'm sorry horse sized
duck that's added backwards because I
don't know that I could really fight all
those cute tiny little horses right that
would be tough but it would be much
easier mentally to fight this like giant
monster of a duck right um anyway
although I think that it would probably
be more dangerous to be around that
giant duck all right so now back to some
code hopefully hopefully I didn't upset
anybody by you know having entertaining
that question there there's only what
maybe like a minute or two of of time we
took on that okay
so Oh harsh it says react sixteen is
coming out with the MIT license instead
of the BSD three clause who's excited
yeah so that's really interesting that
that happen I know we had a question I
think last week about someone asked me
what I thought about the license and
also what I thought about WordPress
deciding not to go with react anymore
because of the license so I've already
given my thoughts on that I'm not going
to repeat them
but I'm I'm actually somewhat surprised
that Facebook decided to change their
license I didn't think that they would
so so that's cool why I think that's
that reassures a lot of people - that's
cool
for me I didn't really care one way or
another for the license I didn't think
it would affect my work that much at
least from what I understood about it so
but I like it
I like that it happened because if the
react community gets bigger it's only
gonna benefit you know it's going to
help all of us right there'll be more
information out there more jobs for
react developers so I think it'll be
good
it'll be good for the react community in
general that the license changed and you
know any any companies that were
hesitant over it before you know maybe
they won't be so hesitant now yeah so
it's a good thing it was surprising but
but good let's see okay cool Jon Hansen
said it read more at the bottom is
generally better so cool that was that's
good a good call that we had this there
at the bottom yeah I do agree I mean
right now we can see it all in one go
but on a smaller screen there'd be some
scrolling so
you know normally if the readmore is up
here you see that first well you might
not be sure whether or not you want to
read more yet you haven't even seen
what's there so I do agree as as you
scroll you get a little taste of what's
there then if you're interested yeah
then you can read more so I don't know
maybe you know maybe there is some data
to show that you get more clicks on a
read more at the top I don't I don't
really know but just logically for me
you know I can definitely understand if
I was going through his site thinking
it'd be more convenient to have the read
more button at the bottom I would
probably look for it at the bottom as
well okay John boys says I think you
typed position instead of postition
instead of position so thanks for
catching that
I didn't look over at the live chat and
see that that would have saved me a
little bit of time trying to figure that
out
uh-hum let's see John Hanson says
interesting section design and for that
we're talking about this design so
saying interesting section design open
no borders you know color image grouping
and easy to see button click I like it
cool yeah yeah when I saw it I was just
I I did I was really kind of impressed
with with this the only the only thing I
thought is man I'd really love to have a
color palette that would work well with
this kind of thing so I'm gonna try it
usually what we do is stick with on
light backgrounds one color for all
buttons and then another color on dark
backgrounds you usually we do that
inverted button on the dark backgrounds
but occasionally we will do a solid
color so this would definitely be
different than what we normally do but
I'm interested in seeing if we took you
know maybe three of the colors that
aren't often used from the university
color palette and use them like this you
know what would it look like I mean this
works especially well because they Eve
match you know all these things so they
have the icon the title of this so it
works they're all so bright you know
kind of playful colors and that's
Google's thing people expect that so I'm
not sure that it would translate well to
Franciscans color palette but we'll see
I'd like to give it a shot I'm not
really hopeful that it'll work out but I
it would be cool to give it give it a
shot okay so Tony says looks like the
formatting shortcut is Shift option F
all right thank you let's try that out
yes thank you so much I'm so happy now
look at that so much nicer so much nicer
- thank you again that's awesome
so I I know we already went over this on
a previous stream but I didn't remember
so I'll repeat it again shift option F
does the auto formatting in Visual
Studio code okay and actually that's it
for the live chat yeah so we might wrap
this up unless anybody has any questions
you can get in there in the next few
seconds we're gonna wrap things up now I
I appreciate you all watching especially
at the earlier time with short notice so
sorry again for the confusion on the
time I'll do my best to double-check
everything you know when I schedule the
stream but anyway that's a good stream I
feel a lot more confident about the
design we have now or at least the plan
for the design it's looking
I mean it's looking really plain right
now so it's not it's not great but I
think we're gonna get somewhere where
it'll be possible to at least show you
know my boss something and get some
feedback and and really start to
fine-tune things this is sorry I'm Berto
says back to pare if it's still going
I'm buried so I'm not sure what you mean
by that anyway let me know I know
there's a delay so it might not get an
answer before I in the stream but I'll
probably be back tomorrow I am feeling a
little bit better yesterday I wasn't
feeling well
I'm feeling a little bit better my
throat is still pretty sore so I mean if
I feel worse tomorrow there's a
possibility I might not come into work
or stream so I'm just I'm not not sure
about it it's really tempting to stay
home but I can't stream from home so
that's one of the reasons why I came in
today and staying home so once I got
going this morning and actually got into
work I did feel a little bit better so
okay I'm Barrett this is Google's people
plus AI whatever the R stands for oh
okay that was streaming to alright I get
it now I get it so anyway
Umberto's said that google has something
streaming about AI right now so saying
we'll go back to that that's cool
actually maybe I'll watch that while I
eat my lunch if it's still going so
thanks for that
umberto alright so like I said be back
probably be back tomorrow we'll see
thanks for watching and yeah and thanks
for getting us to over 200,000
subscribers really really appreciate
that that's awesome
so until tomorrow have a great day